i was cornered from in front of me with  mr zaminski  and there were  there were  [Music]  people right there  see that's real  look the kid's not a professional actor  and i don't think he that's that's an  academy award performance if he is  that's a kid who was overcome with  emotion  and again you're talking about a kid who  was there to put out fire to provide  medical assistance who was there because  he saw a town on fire and gender and it  feels bad that he hurt somebody who was  trying to kill him yeah yeah you know  who doesn't feel that way the person who  runs up and points a gun at somebody who  is not violent toward them the person  who puts on a mask and runs out behind a  car screaming for you and i'll kill you  when they weren't aggressive towards  them and corners them or attacks people  smaller and weaker that are turned  around right  god my heart breaks for that kid yeah